et drag m'évite se demander si tu
accepterais de faire une petite envolée
euros je crois qu aurait un panier de
gousses d'ail pour voler avec toute ma
chérie je regarde ces nuages to hell of
ivy chérie ça va j'ai juste un petit peu
plus de mal à suivre
parce que je suis enceinte roule bien
sur quoi voilà mon petit-fils la lignée
des dans la culasse perpétue c'est sûr
que c'est un vampire
tu as vu ses cheveux et pourrait être
non ça n'arrivera pas c'est gentil petit
pénis
tu te souviens comment marche la webcam
oui oui le téléphone les boutons et le
supplice et en profitons pour la prendre
à ce garçon être vraiment on est complet
le blop désolé vieux ouais je sais pas
juste la malepère font pas nous montrer
comment il fait peur aux gens
tonckens quand même été trop beau sur
une photo bien sûr les filles on se fait
à cette fille je rêve
il va bien cbh lobby m'a pas tuée
on est dans le jardin de l'hôtel et on
se grille quel complot cette femme ne
ressemble pas du tout à l'hôtel je
rentre immédiatement les cas en voiture
il faut le ton merde je suis désolé
bloqués au fond tu es vraiment bornes de
tes nouvelles tout à l'heure les copains
on enclenche le plan b joe là haut
en août c'est un gag ma parole